- I can see someone I knew as a child
and immediately recognize
them as an adult,
or I can see someone who worked at a store
that I used to go to 10 years ago,
and see them on the street and
recognize them as that clerk.
My name is Jennifer Jarrett,
and I'm a super recognizer.
I remember just about every face I see.
I don't have to have
an emotional attachment
to people to remember them.
I really started to recognize
it when I went to college.
I would meet people, I
would always remember them,
and then a couple of months later,
I'd be at a party and people would say,
"Oh, do you two know each other?"
and I'd say yes, and the
other person would say no.
So, then, I sort of started
to learn what was a memorable
encounter and what wasn't.
In terms of being a super recognizer,
so far I haven't really
found any way to utilize it.
At my last college reunion,
my friends were so excited
because, you know, everybody worries
that they're gonna go to a reunion
and not remember who people are,
so people were sticking to me like glue
so I could tell everyone
who was in the room.
(gentle instrumental music)